Benvenuti in un nuovo episodio del Late Show con Karim Musa
E finalmente siamo tornati anche in questo 2018...
...e parto subito col dire che io questo video non lo volevo fare...
... perchè ogni persona caratterialmente è diversa, ovviamente, e io sono una di quelle persone che
è molto brava e si trova molto a suo agio quando deve insultare qualcosa
o distruggerla fino alle proprie fondamenta, lì mi trovo proprio a casa mia.
Ma quando devo parlare bene di qualcosa o devo spiegare i motivi...
...per il quale questa cosa mi suscita determinate emozioni o mi provoca determinati sentimenti...
...ho difficoltà.
Probabilmente questo sarà un video
sconclusionato, confuso, pasticciato... ma è un video che aspettavo di fare da tanto tempo
e credo che sia giunto il momento.
Nei prossimi minuti cercherò di spiegarvi, probabilmente invano,
quanto peso abbiano avuto Paolo Villaggio e le sue opere nella mia vita.
Quando andavo all'Istituto Tecnico per geometri...
ho incontrato uno dei miei professori di disegno tecnico
E un giorno si è messo a spiegarci dei lavori che ha fatto lui a Torino...
"Ho fatto locali di qui, locali di là...
...e anche qualche palazzina che sicuramente voi avrete visto passando per arrivare a scuola".
E noi tutti incuriositi: "Prof quale?"
"Ma sì, quella all'incrocio Tal dei Tali...
quella che ha i buchi quadrati sui balconi!"
E noi ci chiedevamo: "Buchi quadrati sui balconi?! Ma questo qua è ubriaco!"
E lui giustamente ha passato i restanti venti minuti
ad insultarci fino alla sesta generazione.
In modo assolutamente giusto lui ci criticava il fatto che
camminando in città tutti i giorni della nostra vita, 24 ore su 24...
... noi non abbiamo mai alzato lo sguardo.
Alzare lo sguardo? Noi eravamo dei pischelletti! Chissenefrega di alzare lo sguardo!
L'unica cosa che ci importava era la fica!
E lui giustamente diceva: "Certo, ma magari, tra una donzella ed uno spinello... (non so cosa facciate voi giovani)
Provate ad alzare lo sguardo! E provate a guardare la città che voi vivete dalla mattina alla sera...
da un'altra prospettiva".
E 12 anni dopo sono qui a parlare di una delle cose più importanti
e che mi hanno segnato più a fondo di tutta la mia vita: Paolo Villaggio e le sue opere.
E come piace tanto fare alle pagine Facebook dell'ultimo periodo...
partirei con una citazione: "Il comico non diventa mai adulto, resta sempre un bambino".
E il primo ricordo di Fantozzi mi arriva proprio dall'infanzia...
anche se in realtà i ricordi d'infanzia non è che siano proprio tantissimi perchè quel periodo è un po' annebbiato.
Mi ricordo la prima volta che mio padre mi portò al cinema a vedere Jurassic Park...
ero talmente piccolo da non riuscire a gestire l'audio potentissimo del cinema e guardai l'intero film...
...con le mani sulle orecchie.
Un altro dei pochi ricordi, ma molto vividi, sono io che sto giocando alla mia festa di compleanno con i miei amichetti...
e mentre sto sparando con quelle pistole che sparano le palline di plastica molto molto leggere per non farsi male...
...mi cago addosso.
Il ricordo di ogni singola riunione familiare, di ogni singola cena di Natale, compleanno dei parenti,
compleanno dei cugini vari... ricordo che durante le cene, per non lasciare il silenzio ed il rumore...
della gente che mastica dentro i tuoi neuroni, si metteva qualcosa e per non mettere per l'ennesima volta Buona Domenica...
...si metteva qualche videocassetta, ed al 99% delle volte, era un Fantozzi.
Io non c'ho mai pensato, ma è raro trovare un'opera...
il cui creatore sia anche il protagonista.
A volte capita però: per esempio con Woody Allen, lui scrive i film e molto spesso è stato anche...
il protagonista del film... ha scritto monologhi e molto spesso era il protagonista del monologo.
Ma è molto più raro vedere un autore che inventa un personaggio, poi ci scrive dei monologhi comici poi...
interpreta i monologhi comici..
poi ci fa un libro su questo personaggio...
poi ci fanno un film... e l'attore che interpreta...
il protagonista di questo film, che è il protagonista dei libri e che è il protagonista dei monologhi...
è l'autore stesso.
E' quasi come vivere una seconda vita tangibile...
e anche solo scoprire questa banalità intacca profondamente la mia visione delle cose...
e questa è solo la punta dell'iceberg, perchè ogni volta che mi riguardo,
per la centoventisettesima volta tutti i film di Fantozzi...
imparo qualcosa di nuovo. O scopro qualche particolare nuovo, una chiave di lettura nuova...
E questo particolare dell'autorialità totale delle opere di Paolo Villaggio...
mi ha messo una curiosità pazzesca, tanto che sono andato a scavare nella sua carriera e nella sua vita...
Scoprire per esempio della sua incredibile amicizia con Fabrizio De Andrè mi ha scaldato il cuore...
e ancora di più lo ha fatto scoprire che Paolo Villaggio ha scritto insieme a lui la canzone: "Carlo Martello".
e questo quando Paolo aveva 30 anni, Fabrizio ne aveva 22... io cosa cazzo sto facendo nella mia vita?!
Cioè aveva 22 anni De Andrè! Io a 22 anni avevo appena scoperto i server gratuiti di WoW perchè quelli originali non me li potevo permettere...
Villaggio parla tantissimo della sua stretta amicizia con De André anche in ultime interviste, dicendo per esempio...
"Fingevamo di essere brave persone ma eravamo carogne. Da ragazzi tormentavano due omosessuali...
uno dichiarato e l'altro no. Li prendevamo a pietrate solo per il gusto di farlo".
Vedi? Vedi?! Quello che fanno tutti gli amici stretti... no?
Va bene... voglio dire dopo anni e anni di carriera uno scivolone in un'intervista ci sta, poi la mente non è più
giovane e fresca come era un tempo... ma ha fatto anche tantissime altre interviste dove ha dichiarato per esempio...
"L'omosessualità? E' un'anomalia genetica".
Per esempio
Si, ha detto queste cose nelle interviste...
ma io volevo usarle non tanto per gettare fango sulla persona o sulla carriera di Paolo Villaggio...
ma più per aprire un argomento un po' particolare che è sempre un po' controverso.
Quando a voi piacciono le opere di una determinata persona, ma poi
venite a scoprire che essa è, o in parte o del tutto, dipende dalla persona...
un grandissimo figlio di *censura*... cosa fate?
Cioè, la bellezza delle loro opere, per voi, viene intaccata da questa cosa qui?
Diminuisce? Aumenta? Rimane stabile? Non ne ho idea, perchè dipende dalla personalità di ognuno di noi, secondo me,
cercare di dividere magari, o assorbire all'interno, ciò che succede nella vita privata di altre persone.
A me personalmente non intacca quasi per nulla questa cosa. Non perché non sia grave, ma perchè
Il mio cervello dice "Chissenefrega". E io dico "Chissenefrega".
Sono solo contento che Hitler non abbia scritto la canzone di Marinella.
E a luglio del 2017 ho scoperto della sua morte. L'ho scoperto come scopro le morti di tutti
i personaggi famosi: su Twitter. Perché twitter è ormai diventato...
il necrologio del nuovo millennio. E purtroppo noi siamo una generazione un po' sfortunata per quanto riguarda...
le morti, perché noi siamo cresciuti con un sacco di "idoli" della televisione e non...
che pian piano sono morti durante il corso degli anni.
Ma non ho MAI reagito in questo modo qua. Qualcosa vorrà dire. Forse lì mi sono reso conto di quanto
le opere di paolo villaggio fossero importanti per la mia vita.
O forse la reazione è stata così perché è come se avessi perso un parente stretto.
Oppure ho pianto perché tirava le pietre ai gay. Non lo so...
Fatto sta che molto spesso quando
hai un personaggio o un'opera
che ti segue da così tanti anni, ti piacerebbe esprimere la tua gratitudine a questa persona,
all'autore, in qualche modo o nell'altro.
E io non sono mai riuscito a farlo, ma nessuno riesce mai a farlo perché sono un pochino irraggiungibili queste persone qua ovviamente.
E tra l'altro io ci sono andato molto vicino al poter parlare e interagire
con il signor Villaggio. Allora, c'è da dire che io ho interagito nella mia vita con pochissimi VIP veri.
(I miei colleghi youtuber non contano)
Essendo di torino, ho visto in un negozio di dischi Boosta dei Subsonica
Ho visto per strada tipo 150 mila volte i Linea 77,
Daniele Luttazzi ha scritto per ringraziarmi in privato su Twitter per un tweet che feci su di lui 50 anni fa,
Ho fatto dei complimenti a Gianni Fantoni per un suo format su YouTube e lui mi ha risposto con delle emoticon,
Ho dichiarato il mio amore indiscusso, ma non corrisposto di Francesca Michielin...
e lei mi ha risposto con un emoticon... un cuoricino... Mortacci delle emoticon!!!
E poi, non, so se ve lo ricordate, ma anni fa...
Paolo Villaggio aprì un canale di YouTube...
gestito probabilmente dai figli credo (non credo che lo gestisse lui direttamente ovviamente) dove...
dove rispondeva alle domande dei fan. E ovviamente...
essendo Yotobi, feci una domanda nei commenti che andò subito in prima posizione votato dalle persone, e lui la lesse nell'episodio seguente.
Purtroppo non mi ricordo nè la domanda nè quale fu la, risposta però mi ricordo cosa disse all'inizio
della domanda: per fare una piccola battuta sul mio nome disse: "La prossima domanda ce la fa
Yotobi, Yotobi che non è un animale eh, ma è una persona vera!
E io non ho smesso di ridere anche ora! Purtroppo quei video non ci sono più perché sono stati cancellati già un sacco di tempo fa... e mannaggia avrei dovuto scaricarli.
Piccola interruzione di servizio per dirvi soltanto che sono disponibili i biglietti per il nuovo tour
del nuovo spettacolo mio e di Vincenzo, vero Vincè?
Annuncio vobis gaudium magnum, habemus tour! Fumata bianca!
Abbiamo le date del nuovo tour! Dai dai dai!
PS: comunque 'a carbonara co' la panna, NO!
Ho comprato un lettore di vinili! L'ho pagato 50 euro. Non giudicatemi.
Perchè vi faccio vedere questa cosa qui? Per raccontarvi un piccolissimo aneddoto.
Io adoro ascoltare il Jazz.
Non ne sono assolutamente un esperto, però mi sto cimentando
piano piano ad impararne le basi per poi ascoltare roba un po' più complessa.
E che vinili avrò mai comprato al costo di un euro nei mercatini dell'usato?
Ah, per esempio Caterina Caselli!
*in sottofondo: L'Orologio di Caterina Caselli*
Oppure,  andando molto sul classico: Frank Sinatra.
Ma a volte nei mercatini dell'usato si trovano anche cose un po' particolari: come...
"Walter Bonatti vi fa ascoltare le voci meravigliose della natura".
*E a pochi passi da me, vi è un mostro alto più di due metri che eleva il suo grido*
*Suoni della natura*
Ma soprattutto, come ho detto prima: i grandi del Jazz.
E chi, meglio di Jerry Roll Morton, per iniziare ad ascoltarlo.
E di solito non vado neanche per autori specifici, ma prendo proprio "Jazz Special: i grandi incontri".
Ed è qui che volevo arrivare: dentro questa confezione ho notato subito che non c'era
solo un vinile, ma due. Uno è "Jazz Special: I Grandi Incontri", l'altro è Ciak: la commedia all'italiana"
Probabilmente c'è stato un errore: il proprietario avrà messo due vinili nella confezione e...
quando li ha dati al mercatino dell'usato se n'è dimenticato.
E quelli non hanno controllato. Quindi a 3 euro ne ho presi due.
Sono andato a comprare Jazz Special un paio di mesi dopo la morte di Paolo Villaggio...
e dentro mi ritrovo un secondo vinile, completamente a caso, chiamato "La commedia all'italiana"...
la cui quattordicesima canzone è questa.
*in sottofondo "La ballata di Fantozzi"*
Io non so se voi crediate in Dio, nel destino o in qualche forza che comanda il tutto...
Ma questa non può essere una coincidenza.
*Yotobi canta un pezzo de "La ballata di Fantozzi"*
Sai però di cosa dovrei parlare magari?
Dei film, magari. Dovrei parlare dei film.
E' che non bastano dieci ore per parlare dei film. Sai perchè non ho mai parlato di Paolo Villaggio spesso, soprattutto dei suoi film?
Perchè... non ho abbastanza cultura. Non sono abbastanza acculturato per riuscire a parlare
dei film di Paolo Villaggio. Quindi, come ogni mio video, non è tanto sui particolari tecnici o sulle recensioni
specifiche, ma è molto più sull'empatia. I film di fantozzi sono un oceano di informazioni e
di tipologie di comicità.. e di tipologia di scrittura.
Per esempio, c'è un sacco di comicità becera nei film di Paolo Villaggio, ma c'è anche un sacco di
satira, e anche un sacco di slapstick comedy.
Infatti crescendo con questa tipologia di film, ho iniziato, nel corso degli anni...
ad apprezzare anche personaggi come Buster Keaton per esempio.
Però una cosa l'ho fatta in tutto questo periodo:
ho guardato in alto. Guardando tutto da un'altra prospettiva sono finalmente riuscito a...
capire, a concepire una mia piccola teoria sul come Villaggio e Fantozzi costruiscono...
una battuta o uno sketch. E siccome TUTTO funziona meglio con gli esempi... dovrei farmene una maglietta
"Tutto funziona meglio con gli esempi" (Cit. Yotobi)... vi faccio un esempio.
Perchè i film di Fantozzi funzionano quando sei piccolo, quando sei adolescente e quando sei un adulto?
Perchè le battute contenute al suo interno funzionano su tre livelli diversi
infantile, adolescenziale ed adulto.
Questa è la scena in cui Fantozzi scopre che Pina lo tradisce con Cecco, il figlio del fornaio.
E come lo capisce che viene tradito? Beh, ovviamente, come tutti sapete
Ha la cucina completamente tappezzata di pane ovunque: nei cassetti, nel frigorifero, nel freezer, sui mobili ecc.
"A questo punto venne colto da un leggero sospetto"
Come fa questo sketch a funzionare su tre livelli diversi?
A livello infantile perché quando sei piccolo ridi di questa scena per quanto sia surreale il fatto che ci sia pane ovunque.
A livello adolescenziale funziona perchè tu essendo adolescente hai delle capacità cognitive
leggermente superiori a quelle che avevi prima, e ti fa ridere il fatto che lui ha la moglie che lo tradisce con un panettiere...
E quindi casa sua è piena di pane.
A livello adulto ti fa ridere perché riesci a capire esattamente
cosa volesse esprimere con questo sketch. Cioè che l'uomo medio, quello che rappresenta Fantozzi, è un idiota.
Anche con le prove davanti palesi, fa fatica a capire quando la moglie lo tradisce!
L'unica differenza nei film di Fantozzi con questa impostazione classica di una battuta...
E' che, alla fine, non si ride.
Infatti c'è questo filo nei film di Fantozzi, questo filo invisibile che li unisce tutti.
Questo filo di tristezza, di malinconia, di angoscia, di depressione che tu riesci a percepire in questa terza fase adulta.
Nella fase in cui riesci a capire cosa Paolo Villaggio volesse dire con questo sketch qua.
Fiù! E' stato un parto questo video perchè
voi non avete idea del montaggio che ci sarà dietro
perché mi sono incespicato 130 mila volte perchè è veramente un discorso troppo complesso da fare
in un video YouTube. YouTube è stretto, è troppo stretto!
Non si può fare questo tipo di video queste analisi lunghissime non ho voglia!
Non ho voglia però voglio parlarne, e quindi perdonatemi se se è stato tutto un pasticcio...
Però ho sentito la necessità di farlo.
Quindi ci vediamo in un prossimo episodio dello Show.